and that's why my middle-out compression
software is going to be the absolute
best way that we can revolutionize
lossless audio compression and and
really like remake this industry so are
you willing to invest in my company look
thanks for the thing guys your
technology is really interesting and all
that but we've seen a thousand
compression plays and none of the
moments and all that successful so why
do you think you'll succeed in where
others have it I have the best tech our
algorithms are better than anyone else
out there I don't know how you can't see
it and I follow the path to success
because I'm wearing a suit I need a
hoodie would you invest then so this for
me is one of the most important moments
of my career I'm striding away at a
zombie job at hooli and I'm unhappy with
my life and I have this amazing
algorithm that's gonna help me just
realize my full potential and I'm gonna
be the happiest person and if I can make
this new product that really changes the
world that's what I came to Stanford for
originally anyways right but I was so
fraud things IV my palms are sweaty I'm
nervous I'm pitting out below this
jacket and I blew it but what if there
was a different approach I can take
today Robert Lesley
we're going to show you the tools of
improvisation they will allow you one to
celebrate failure but allow you to
really change the outcome of these kinds
of situations so that instead of
freaking out you really can take the
opportunity to embrace and just become
everyone you the person you want to be
we're going to walk through a couple of
specific scenarios where you're going to
learn anxiety management we're gonna
learn a little bit of how we can
brainstorm in an effective way and then
we're gonna learn lastly how to just be
a better teammate and co-worker for your
friends so with that let's so you guys
all just saw read sweat bullets in front
of a board of VC investors incorrectly
in front of all of you guys so a
important lesson improv is to celebrate
failure the one that when an actor makes
a mistake he misses a cue or she messes
up a line they're taught to smile take a
bow and say tada and that's top now this
is really important because it
transforms that negative energy you have
around making a mistake into a
celebration of boldness it's a way of
saying aye aye it's a way of owning your
mistakes and saying the show goes on
you're basically saying I took a risk I
failed I'm still here I learned
something
tada now of course it'd be pretty
awkward to take a bow in the middle of a
boardroom but how do we transfer the
lessons the mentality of the failure bow
into the business world I have three
tips for you today
first greet anxiety accept it let it
become part of you now I personally get
very anxious before presentations
sometimes get a little sweaty it's not
good and then try to fight it but I've
learned that the more I tried to untie
that knot in my stomach but tighter it
gets the more nervous I become I have
since then learn to just let it be
recognized that it's part of the process
say hmm there's that sinking feeling my
stock go again
that's good that's normal I should
expect this it's part of the process
because I'm about to do something great
now the nervousness doesn't go away but
my naming it and by calling it out I've
taken away some of the power it has over
me the next thing that you can do is be
average be okay with ordinary now a lot
of the stress that we place in ourselves
come from our own expectations to do
great things to really excel to be
stellar to knock that ball out of the
park but let's just be honest for a
minute here those are our expectations
of ourselves that's not what the
audience expects the audience expects
the business to go on the shoulder go on
they expect nothing more than that of
the ordinary now I'm not saying don't be
stellar I'm not saying don't excel you
should absolutely do that but at the
same time be kind to yourselves if the
outcome is just okay if the outcome is
just average that's perfectly acceptable
as a matter of fact that's expected
lastly embrace the unknown see it as an
opportunity to learn oftentimes we get
into the situation about me versus the
world situation where you threw a
question at me I don't know how to
answer it I feel like it's attacked and
they get anxious because I'm defenseless
let's see if we can reframe that rather
than say this is some hack on me say
this question I don't know what an
answer is an imitation it's an
invitation to say hmm that's a really
good question that I don't know the
answer can you help you with it
what can we work on it together by that
reframing you've turned to this question
that put you on the spot into a hatful
conversation so the next time you're in
that boardroom that the next time that
you mess up the next time you feel that
anxiousness take a mental bow recognize
your mistake and move on
speaking of move on let's move on to our
next scene with Audrey
all right guys it's brainstorming time
we need to come up with a way to
increase our sales on our product what
do you think what if we offered to pay
off all their student loans if they did
a free trial oh my god that's gonna be
so expensive how about we meet them
person the personnel so that's gonna
take forever it's not gonna work oh well
we just witnessed was a very ineffective
brainstorming session where every idea
thrown out Victoria just said no and
shut it down
an improv the number one rule is say yes
to everything it's the first thing that
you learn as an improviser so suppose
we're doing an improv scene that I'm in
with another actor in the wilderness for
example and I say let's climb this
mountain if the other actor says no I
don't really want to kind of kills the
whole scene right instead we're taught
to say yes so if the other actor says
yes let's go climb that mountain it
helps the scene move forward we can use
this same principle of saying yes and
apply it back to this business
brainstorming session so if Reid had
asked the court had suggested what if we
send emails out if Victoria just says no
that kind of kills the whole vibe so
instead apply the principle of saying
yes and if she said yes Reid great idea
that creates a much more positive
brainstorming environment and obviously
in brainstorming you're not going to end
up actually taking every idea proposed
but simply by saying yes it creates a
lot more creativity and a much more
effective session sometimes in no can be
disguised as a yes but so back to our
improv example if I say let's climb this
mountain and the other actor says yes
but actually I'm afraid of heights
they've said yes but effectively that's
a no so an improv instead of just saying
yes what we want to say is yes and so
yes let's climb this mountain and let's
try to do it as fast as we possibly can
so adding something contributing more to
move the scene forward and now taking
this back once again to our brains
in session and even more effective
response than the Victoria just say yes
let's send emails would be to add to it
to say yes and we can have a promo code
in that email so people are even more
likely to click to buy a product saying
yes and one of the most effective tools
from improv that we can apply to
brainstorming and now let's take it back
to another scene for a final scene yeah
that's a great how come before I'm
supposed to just that week hey guys so
we need to decide on our final topic
what do you think any ideas oh I think
we should do improv I mean I don't think
it's regular II just said it okay I'll
just came up with it pops well we just
saw here it was caught stealing the show
and that violates a top rule in improv
that is making your partner look great
in improv there's a saying that goes
every actor is supposed to be a
supporting actor but how do you exactly
do that top one rule go to rule just
listen what exactly do I mean by that
let me show you a story in a Tibetan
temple an old master was trying to show
a young monk the truth to life he held
up a tea pot and started pouring tea
into the cup and as the Kiehl's
overflowing the young monk was getting
very anxious and the old master was like
well you are like this teacup you
already filled with ideas and thoughts
you need to empty yourself in order to
taking anything that I say so just
listen in modern society it is way too
easy to listen just enough to respond
instead of listening to understand the
whole thing
and that is why either be an improv or
in a business scene we should listen to
understand the whole thing instead of
listen just enough to respond to what is
being said so now you're thinking okay
I'm gonna listen I'm gonna sit back and
enjoy the show put on by my partners but
guess what you're still part of the show
so when your partner is stuck on a scene
instead of just floating and that
awkward silence and just listening to
the awkward silence there I'll throw out
an idea like oh hey it's bright and
sunny outside to allow your partner to
say oh okay let's go to a picnic at the
Oval and that would be the same case in
business things in conference room
initiate an idea even if it's not the
best idea ever
it will allow your teammates to come up
with maybe better ideas and last but not
least add not replace this is another
version of the yes and attitude that
Otto just mentioned before because you
want to make your teammates feel like
the end product is their proud baby it's
their idea so that they can putting the
maximum effort into the entire project
because by making your teammates and
making your partner's the heroes of the
show you're actually becoming the hero
of the team and now let's take it back
to read we've all been in these really
awful situations where we just felt down
in the dumps after we blew a big meeting
because we were too nervous we couldn't
get that VC pitch made right or even
worse we were working with a co-worker
who stabbed us in the back on their path
to power
and we're gonna face those situations
again that's gonna happen to you me to
all of us but now we're armed with a new
set of tools that allows us to choose
how we deal with those problems and
making that choice to change your
attitude can revolutionize the outcome
Robert taught us to celebrate failure
Audrey to say yes and in Victoria to be
a better teammate and whether you're
trying to pitch a VC or you're working
out an issue with your spouse or just
trying to be playful again just remember
to make work like play and think like an
improviser and you may just surprise
yourself with the kind of creativity you
come up with the kind of solutions you
work out to problems that seemed
otherwise difficult